[Applause]
arriving at court in Para limine the
British teenager was met by a crowd of
supporters most of these women came from
Israel eager to make their views clear
on cypresses criminal justice system I
can see with my eyes so many failures
that happen here also as an Israeli I
think about these youngsters who came
back to my country inside the court the
19 year old was told by the judge he was
giving her a second chance a suspended
sentence for public mischief that in
effect means she can go home the first
time in six months her mother then came
out to speak rubbing face making sure
that we get justice thank you all of you
for turning up her daughter had been
staying at this hotel while on a working
holiday in the resort of iron ather when
she went to the police alleging she'd
been gang-raped twelve Israelis were
quickly arrested and then released after
the woman retracted her accusations she
says the police forced her to do this
the court decided she was lying what
happens or didn't happen in this
building six months ago it was helped
expose a range of different issues how
women are listened to when they say
they've been raped the behavior of young
tourists in party resorts like iron a
per the relationship between Cyprus and
the UK and Israel and whether the
justice system here is working as it
should be the teenagers legal team point
to a list of potential police violations
questioning her with no lawyer or
translator present and not recording
what was said it's the police officers
word against the victim and of course
there's no recourse for the victim so
we're hoping that if this case does go
to the European Court of Human Rights
that that problem can be redressed and
that perhaps Cyprus can fall into line
with other modern jurisdictions her
Cypriot lawyer thinks the country does
too little to help
I believe we have a culture that needs
to start changing when it comes to
violence against women and it is this
culture that creates the systemic
problems that we are facing here in
Cyprus the case has disturbed relations
between London and Nicosia between my
first concern has been her welfare
we will be following up on some of the
issues in relation to the case I spoke
to the Cypriot foreign minister about
that but there was also a warning from
the UK foreign minister in the summer
season resorts such as iron a / are
thronging with youngsters drinking and
partying hard Dominik Rob says Brits
abroad should look after themselves
Rory challon's al Jazeera I am a / and
peril in me well we're joined now from
Nicosia by zeliha Gregorio who organized
one of the protests outside the court
Madame thank you so much for joining us
here on al Jazeera so obviously
organized one of the protests there it
seems obvious you don't believe that the
Justin sister justice system is working
in this case explain to us why this
woman who has been violated repeatedly
by multiple kinds of power and same
group network
when we attended the court session last
time on the 30th we were very distressed
to see how effectively she was addressed
by the judge how he tried to make
excuses for regulating her but most
importantly we were embarrassed to hear
the judge when he came to the point
before announcing his verdict she share
with the audience his appreciation of
the reliability of the of the of the
witness he referred to the video and
actually he referred to the video of a
night of consensual sex he referred to
that she support his opinion that she
was
unreliable witness for us sitting there
it was a trembling moment to realize how
a moralistic discourse was so easily
permitting a judge's evaluation of a
female witness at that point we knew
that this was a very complicated
multi-layered kind of rape before of
course the girl was before the judge she
went and reported the alleged rape to
the police and then she says that the
police effectively put pressure on her
to retract the accusation just explain
to us why you think the police would do
that okay first let me clarify something
the first person who notified the police
was the doctor of the of the place which
is not quite a resort where this girl
stayed he was the first one to see her
in such a desolate state semi naked
crying in the corridors of that of those
apartments hotel whatever that is and he
was the one to call the police and tell
them what's going on and they said and
they immediately contacted and I don't
know who took the girl to the police
report so it was not just her there was
in this case what is essentially
important in cases of reporting rape
immediate reporting of the of the
incident second ten days passed since
the arrest of the suspects during those
ten days she testified she gave a
description detailed description of the
events three times there was not a
single discrepancy or contradiction in
what she said I on the other hand there
were so many contradictions in me for
interrupting we're just slightly running
out of time I would ask you a question
that kind of links into what we're
talking about now we heard from one of
the lawyers of the girls saying that
really this is an issue of
culture that the culture there needs to
change explain to us why you think what
you think the problem is with the
culture in Cyprus that in your opinion
would lead to a woman who makes an
accusation of rape to effectively not be
believed okay threesies when we talk to
culture we can say the usual thing about
patriarchal misogynist culture we do
have it here but there's also another
kind of culture a culture that says
citizens shouldn't question the
government because our government knows
best
if you question that your government
you're almost considered to be saying
say to your government whereas this is a
very this is the essence of
constitutional authorities and the third
element has to do specifically with the
culture not just afraid of a Inaba I've
heard so many news British news
referring to Inaba as a party child it
is a party town and you see young people
they are getting drunk vomiting laughing
being promiscuous and sexual and all
that stuff and in in short bodies out of
order and people have taboos when they
see both is out of order
they want to put them in order they want
to punish them this is wrong they think
they have the right to punish them for
being who they are at the same time this
is the last thing I want to say the
Israeli women said these people could
have read my daughter what came out in
that statement was that in those Israeli
woman's fear or sensitivity there was
such a deep appreciation of how precious
the life of young civilians egregore
we're going to have to leave it there
unfortunately as electric or organized
one of those protests outside the court
Madame thank you